hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben freunde morgen ist weihnachten
von daher habe ich mir gedacht da gehen
wir heute mal auf die krassesten
weihnachtsfans das hier ist vereins und
ich glaube nicht jeder sieht schon was
hier entscheiden bisschen komisch
animiert wurde
ja ich esse meine pancakes auch am
liebsten wenn da vorher ein
weihnachtsmann drauf gepisst hat der
nächste weihnachtsfest von einem pudding
geschäft und zwar an sich gedacht hey
wir stellen uns vor die tür nicht
irgendeinen weihnachtsbaum in der
lichterkette sondern einen großen
schokoladenpudding sieht allerdings eher
aus wie ein stück scheiße haben
allerdings direkt zum nächsten feld an
weihnachten und zwar ich weiß nicht wie
er dazu steht aber ich bin ziemlich blöd
wenn tiere verschenkt werden zu
weihnachten und gerade besonders blöd
ist es wenn diese tiere dann auch noch
so verpackt dass am nächsten
weihnachtsfeier geht es um dekoration
und zwar um genau zu sein um einen engel
und auf den ersten blick sieht ja
vielleicht ganz normal aus aber wenn man
ran zoomt denkt man sich nur so wer hat
dir denn bitte eine backpfeife verpasst
ja und was auch ein bisschen verstören
aussieht ist das hier denn das sind
irgendwie so sechs verschiedene beeren
weihnachten mäßig angezogen sind aber
die gucken alle so als hätten sie ein
bisschen zu viel marihuana geraucht
haben wir allerdings direkt zum nächsten
weihnachtszeit und zwar ist es dieser
hier auf den ersten blick denkt man sich
erstmal was ist denn daran jetzt
einfällt aber in der überschrift
beziehungsweise bei dem titel bzw bei
dem wie nennt man das die beschreibung
des produktes oder so auf jeden fall ist
die beschreibung bell shakovets mensch
das ist ja wahnsinn das wäre genauso
wenig im supermarkt und dann steht da
apfel sieht aus wie ein apfel
nee das wäre nicht so ja es sei auf
jeden fall genauso wenig in den
supermarkt gehen würde und da würde
stehen ein wie ein apfel geformter apfel
dass ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht dass
jetzt der nächste weihnachtsfest uns war
es das tatsächlich in deutschland und
das ist eine lichterketten dekoration in
der innenstadt und man denkt sich schon
so war sieht irgendwie schön aus aber
irgendwie sieht auch aus wie ein
schlüpfen
wer denkt sich denn jammern
das geht überhaupt nicht falsch aus dass
jetzt der nächste war das feld und 2 ist
das eine aufblasbare weihnachtsmann
puppe die die eigentlich an ihrem
schornstein befestigt hatten allerdings
ist die luft raus gegangen und jetzt
sieht so aus als ob der weihnachtsmann
nackt in den schornstein rein geklettert
ist und sein kostüm da hat liegen lassen
allein diese tatsache dass der
weihnachtsmann durch den schornstein
kletterte er wird euch das auch immer so
eingetrichtert allgemein wird mich aber
von euch interessieren das könnte mir
immer gerne in die kommentare schreiben
ob ihr so richtige weihnacht rituale
habt zum beispiel in ein paar tagen also
jetzt am donnerstag kommt ja dass dick
und doof weihnachts-special raus von
sandra und mir also eine podcast folge
die wir zum aller ersten mal nicht nur
auf spotify und apple podcasts etc laden
sondern auch auf youtube weil wir uns
gegenseitig ein geschenk machen und dann
fühlen wir uns dabei allerdings wollte
ich noch mal ganz kurz davor
vorwegnehmen dass sandra mir in der
folge gesagt hat dass bei denen immer
noch eine person als weihnachtsmann
verkleidet reinkommt und die dann alle
lieder singen und so weiter und so fort
und so das was sie falsch gemacht haben
im jahr vorgetragen bekommen haben also
habt ihr auch so eine tradition weil wir
hatten so was glaube ich noch nie machen
allerdings weiter mit dem nächsten
weihnachtsfest und was ist das hier
da brauche ich glaube ich gar nicht mehr
viel zu sagen das ist das sind palmen
die geschmückt wurden mit lichterketten
im ausland und ja also viel mehr braucht
man da wirklich nichts zu sagen
allerdings sei weiter mit dem nächsten
weihnachtsfest allerdings diesmal nicht
um irgend welchen schmuck geht oder um
lichterketten oder um eine verteilte
weihnachtsdekoration oder so sondern es
geht um ein kleines mädchen
die allerdings nicht geschrieben hat
einer center also ich liebe den
weihnachtsmann sondern isle of satan
[Musik]
ja da hast du dich auf jeden fall leicht
verschrieben das ist der nächste
weihnachtsfest und auf märkten bedenkt
man sich auch wieder so okay sie
eigentlich ganz normal aus weil ein
bisschen genauer hinguckt sieht man
schon dass sind red in green shotgun
highlights also das sind so lichter die
aussehen wie schott kann patronen also
das ist auf jeden fall auch super
gewählt die form und das design das
jetzt der nächste weihnachtsfeier ihr
seht schon was dort steht und zwar jump
for joy und dann ein weihnachtsmann der
in einer brücke steht und wer kommt denn
auf die idee in der stadtverwaltung oder
im bürgerbüro oder keine ahnung wer da
beschließt wer denkt sich denn daher
kommen wir hängen an eine brücke jump
for joy also springen ausgenutzt den
weihnachtsmann oder schön hinhängen
fährt hat euch ins hirn geschissen was
hier ist der nächste weihnachtsfest und
ich glaube meine oma hatte früher auch
solche komischen figuren die so gesungen
haben und ich meine wenn man keine bösen
schwarzen gedanken hat dann ist das auch
komplett normal aus wenn man das
allerdings ein bisschen genauer
betrachtet man das auch irgendwie falsch
verstehen was man auch falsch verstehen
könnte ist das 4
[Musik]
wer
er kommt allein auf solche ideen die
schokolade dann so zu formen machen war
jedoch direkt weiter mit dem nächsten
weihnachtlichen veh und zwar es ist das
hier
es ist ein mac kaffeebecher und darauf
steht gomez greetings und normalerweise
haben sich die leute da wahrscheinlich
gedacht hey da sind zwei hände und die
am walde diesen becher in der hand und
stoßen anders sieht es allerdings so aus
als würde dort eine presse und die
proben auf einander ziehen und warmes
greetings aus scheiße also falls sie
noch nicht in weihnachtsstimmung seit
durch mein video jetzt seid ihr es
definitiv und mal ganz kurz ein kleiner
exkurs zum thema weihnachtsstimmung also
ich bin ja eher seit jahren schon nicht
mehr so richtig in weihnachtsstimmung
weil in köln gefühlten nie schnee liegt
und weil ich alleine wohne und halt
meine wohnung auch nicht so krass mücke
allerdings ist dieses jahr besonders
schön weil es sind gerade 15 grad in
köln
das hatten wir vor ein paar jahren nicht
mal im sommer hier in deutschland lieber
wärme und machen wir jedoch direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten weihnachtsfest
und was ist das hier denn die servierten
die gläser reim er ich bin echt
begeistert und wovon ich auch begeistert
bin ich von dem nächsten weihnachtsfest
und zwar dass dieser hier den hatten wir
glaube ich schon mal in einem anderen
video wo es auch um irgendwelche fails
ging ich glaube da ging es um amazon
oder shopping sales und hier ist es halt
auch wieder der fall das soll ein wie
vor erster bild ist und man denkt sich
wow die tasse verwandelt sich dann wenn
was drin ist aber nun habe ich letztens
mal schon zu krass darüber gelacht alter
so witzig dass jetzt der nächste
weihnachtsfeier und da sage ich einfach
mal nicht zum kombi nun allerdings
wieder zu einer komischen dekoration
beziehungsweise zu einer komischen
lichterkette oder licht
weihnachtsdekoration wie auch immer das
heißen mag
auf jeden fall ist es das hier und ich
meine klar das sind ganz normale kerzen
mit unten christbaumkugeln also sieht
überhaupt nicht falsch aus
kommt doch solche ideen ich meine
realität wenn du dein eigener garten ist
oder dein eigener kleiner privater
einfahrt garagen abschnitt dann kann man
das ja gern machen allerdings ist es bei
so einer stadt sache besonders wenn die
ganzen stadt dann so die lichter hatte
und so dann ist es ja auch von der stadt
entschieden
dann gibt es ja leute die dann wirklich
sagen ja das ist das sehr weihnachtlich
aus das genehmigen wir also ich schecks
nicht was ich auch nicht checke ist
beziehung ja okay ich würde ja ich würde
auch machen welches feiern würde aber
ist es dass sie vorhin bei diesen ganzen
großen boote mit den ganzen beim
ja und was auch hummer als ist dass wir
[Musik]
mein humor und viel zu bescheuert
allerdings nun auch schon zum vorletzten
christmas feld für dieses heutige video
und zwar hat dort eine person sein
geschenk mit geschenkpapier eingepackt
womit auch sonst ja womit auch sonst
luke hat seine geschenke letztes jahr
mit zeitungspapier eingepackt
allerdings geht es bei diesem
weihnachtsfest wirklich um richtiges
weihnachtliches geschenkpapier und auf
dem weihnachtlichen geschenkpapier steht
eigentlich drauf let it snow
allerdings nicht nebeneinander
geschrieben let it snow sondern
untereinander und bevor ich hier weiter
um heißen brei lover zeige ich euch
einfach mal also das l wurde
abgeschnitten und das no würde dann nach
unten gesetzt dann schon dort halt tipps
na ja wenn du dass deine freundin
schenken wird es auf jeden fall witzig
und nun meine lieben freunde kommen wir
auch schon zum letzten weihnachtsfeier
für die heutige episode ich weiß ihr
habt alle drauf gewartet dass jetzt
dieser letzte weihnachtsfest kommt und
ich glaube keiner drauf gewartet
allerdings habe ich ihn trotzdem uns was
ist das hier es ist kein richtiger fail
sondern es ist mehr wirklich eine
kreative erfindung wahrscheinlich von
männern weil das sind alles bierflaschen
und oben der weihnachtsstern der oben
drauf sitzt kann man auch leicht
erkennen das sind bierdeckel tatsächlich
also das war auf jeden fall haben wir
krass an der stelle würde ich allerdings
das heutige jetzt auch bei händlern
lieben freunde wenn euch diese episode
bzw
episode zeigt eine serie hier von mir
dass ich euch weihnachtswelt zeige
allerdings wenn euch das heutige video
gefallen haben wir diesen weihnachtszeit
sind das unbedingt einen daumen hoch
unternehmen das schaffen wir für
zigtausend das war krass ist eine große
zahl hat weiß ich schreibe gern mal
wirklich wie vorhin schon gesagt und in
die kommentare ob ihr so weihnachts
rituale habt das wird mich auch mal
interessieren es gibt ja haushalte wo
wirklich seit jahren gepredigt
es gibt gar keinen weihnachtsmann und
dann sparen sich die eltern dieses ganze
hackmack mit der ganzen lügerei und so
weiter und so fort aber ja das würde
mich echt mal interessieren abonniert
gerne einen kanal falls noch kein teil
der luchs usaid und morgen kommt auf
einem kanal eine jahres zusammenfassung
von meinem jahr 2019 meinem beschissen
ssten jahr bisher tatsächlich und dann
will ich ein bisschen quatschen einfach
wollte mich von kamin setzen die ist das
also morgen kommt zum lama video also
freut euch darauf schon mal und jetzt
kommt doch nicht das auto und ich lass
euch in ruhe
[Musik]